what up space fam goes in here from
anime out pro back at it again with
another one piece video and this time
i'm finally focusing on blackbeard for
an entire video and i'm psyched for it
of course he was mentioned in other
videos like all yonko powers all yonko
backstories and all logia fruits but
it's not the same as devoting an entire
video to this legendary antagonist and
speaking of logia fruits we're going to
explore how blackbeard's devil fruit is
likely not what we thought it was and
this seems all the more obvious after
the latest developments in the one piece
story so make sure to stay tuned for
this one if you do enjoy these videos
and want to keep them coming you know
what to do chill the paraking within and
smash that like button remember smashing
that like button is power king energy
and passing is scared of rochi energy so
choose wisely if you haven't make this
the video you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece videos and updates and while
you wait for future vids and chapters to
drop feel free to check out my big and
growing one-piece playlist that includes
those vids on all the yonko but also
vids on all fruits admirals warlords and
much more link to that is in the
description and now without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all so
as you hopefully know by now it was
revealed in chapter 1044 that luffy
doesn't have the paramecia gomugo munomi
but rather he has the zone human human
fruit mythical model nika thus his power
isn't just rubber he is a mythical zone
user with sun god powers one of which
happens to be having a rubber body i saw
some comments in my chapter review
asking how he was immune to lightning if
he's not rubber but he still has the
properties of rubber and we should keep
that in mind we shouldn't view him as
losing anything but as gaining
additional powers associated with the
sun god nika in most cases the
government got away with convincing
people it was only a rubber fruit
because it didn't awaken for 800 years
and presumably before awakening the user
pretty much just had rubber properties
but now luffy has awakened it and the
truth is out this obviously allows us to
be more skeptical of other fruits as
well and if they really are what it's
been claimed that they are obviously we
can't go crazy with this and assume all
fruits are named wrong because the
government said that they gave that one
specific fruit another name meaning the
sun god fruit so they talked about a
specific fruit and not multiple fruits
however before these last few years a
lot of people would have thought that
luffy having a different fruit was a
ridiculous idea and by comparison the
idea of blackbeard having a mythical
zone rather than a special logia seems
like less of a stretch but let me
explain why it would make a lot of sense
for blackbeard to already have a
mythical zone luffy and blackbeard have
always been compared and they have
always paralleled each other i think
most of us believe that blackbeard will
be one of the final and most important
antagonists that luffy will have to
overcome there are many videos on
youtube exploring how blackbeard is a
character foiled to luffy how his
journey and beliefs mirror luffy's own
but have a darker spin on them and even
how their fruits actually look very
similar even before this reveal that
luffy had the sun god fruit people
suggested that luffy's fruit might be
the perfect counter to blackbeard's
devil fruit the two have always been
like yin and yang luffy representing the
giving sun and black be representing the
taking darkness so it hit me instead of
trying to cram the dark dark fruit into
the logia category despite its obvious
differences to other logia maybe it's
time to reconsider the fruit in light of
the latest chapter and the reveal of
luffy's actual fruit we know that
blackbeard searched his whole life for
the dark dark fruit and he'd memorized
all the shapes of the fruits in the
identification manual so he'd instantly
realize when he saw the fruit what's
important to note here is that he just
used the manual to identify the fruit in
all likelihood blackbeard had more
information on the fruit than what was
written in the identification manual
otherwise way more people would be
obsessed with it blackbeard through one
way or another learned more about its
mysterious and true nature and only that
explains why he and no one else was
willing to search for it his whole life
and even kill his own crew member in
order to get it it's clear that
blackbeard has a connection to the
legendary pirate rox d zebek who ruled
the seas with the strongest crew before
gold d rogers era of prominence not only
have they both been portrayed as
similarly dark figures but blackbeard
even named his own ship the sabre of
zebek in fact i'd say zebek is to
blackbeard but goldie roger who also
once wore the straw hat is to luffy they
both seem to carry the other's will
zebek may have been the previous owner
of the dark dark fruit as well and
because of this connection to zebek
blackbeard may know exactly how
significant the dark dark fruit was
there are even theories that blackbeard
may have been zebek's biological son and
that's possible but not necessary to
establish their obvious connection and
similarities like zebek blackbeard
decided to build his crew by putting
together powerful pirates and not like
luffy by putting together people he
liked even if they didn't start out the
strongest we'll come back to this but if
zabek did have the dark dark fruit
before blackbeard and since we know
after chapter 1044 that zone throughs
carry a will of their own the
similarities in blackbeard and zebek
could in part be explained through their
sharing the same fruit that manifested
its will in both of them and perhaps
even carried over a part of zebek into
blackbeard this would also help explain
why people always comment on how it
seems like there is more than one
blackbeard personality wise but why is
it problematic to keep viewing the dark
dark fruit as a logia in fact blackbeard
even said the ace behold a rarity even
among the logia fruits end quote he has
the fruit he'd surely know right well
luffy didn't know that he had a mythical
zone so it's possible blackbeard doesn't
know but with blackbeard it's also
possible that he is deliberately being
misleading because as we know you can't
trust him he's a literal backstabber
perhaps he keeps using the common
understanding of the dark dark fruit as
a logia because he can use that
misunderstanding to his advantage down
the line we know he's want to hold back
info until it's absolutely necessary to
reveal it so here's some unique stuff
that blackbeard's fruit does that is
unlike other logia for starters
blackbeard says this fruit is said to be
the most dangerous power in the history
of all fruit powers i don't know about
you and this might just be personal
preference but i'd sooner believe that
such a description is referring to the
rare mythical zone fruits rather than to
a logia fruit after all as we've seen
mythical zones can sometimes use logia
type powers in addition to other
additional high powers think of how much
superior marco's fruit is to the normal
flame fruit despite their similarities
aside from sucking in things and being
able to crush them with so so-called
dark gravity that has so called infinite
power which you could say is a bit
similar to the logia swamp swamp fruit
that can also absorb things and spit
them out later blackbeard's fruit does
not allow him to avoid attacks you know
how attacks usually just pass through a
skilled logia user well that's not the
case with blackbeard which even ace
noted is odd if his powers are logia
type an attack like the one ace fired at
him shouldn't hurt blackbeard if he has
a logia type or at least that's what ace
was saying is it just me or does this
have the same feel as when kaido said
rubber shouldn't act like this recently
as he was fighting against luffy
blackbeard is upset and answers and i
quote i told you darkness sucks in
everything whether it's punches blades
bullets fire or lightning end quote
doesn't it seem weird that someone as
smart as blackbeard would be so willing
to give away his weaknesses unless he
was so concerned with ace not figuring
out that it was in fact a mythical zone
and not a logia blackbeard goes on to
explain that he can't turn into fire
like ace and avoid attacks his body
absorbs all pain and that pain is
amplified in the process but in exchange
for that he can use black vortex the
gravity of darkness can pull in the
actual body of devil fruit users sort of
like how the moon is set to pull on
waves so the question is could we be
dealing with a moon god fruit to
contrast luffy's sun god fruit this
would go with the whole yin and yang
forces clashing that luffy and
blackbeard represent besides that if we
look at the outro for the one-piece film
z we see characters as kids and doing
stuff that relate to their future like
mihawk holding a sword and stuff like
that a younger blackbeard is shown with
the moon above and there's obviously
darkness around the moon like there
would be at nighttime so just as luffy
will bring the dawn blackbeard might be
associated with a god of the night slash
the moon both of which are obviously
associated with darkness this would also
go nicely with the fact that he doesn't
seem to sleep at night it makes sense
that a god of the night wouldn't during
their fight blackbeard reveals he can
also absorb the power of the fruits and
so when he's holding ace he can hit him
while preventing him from using his
abilities like seastone again why would
this apply to a darkness logia we
definitely don't have anything
comparable with what would otherwise
supposed to be its logia counterpart the
light light fruit and although they keep
it mysterious i think it's fair to say
that blackbeard was most likely able to
absorb whitebeard's own fruit and take
it for himself by using his dark dark
fruit after all that does seem like the
natural progression of his darkness
being able to absorb the power of the
fruits which he says it can do to ace
then as a summons a giant fiery orb that
looks like the sun blackbeard himself
says the sun or the darkness only one of
us will win end quote and at the time it
seems like he's referring to asus
sun-like attack but of course ace is
actually associated with fire not the
sun so it's possible that blackbeard was
thinking ahead when he said that and not
just about the immediate fight in front
of him and so now that we know that
luffy has the sun fruit it could be red
as blackbeard saying only his darkness
or luffy's son will win and since luffy
is a sun god wouldn't it make more sense
given everything else we covered that
his main antagonist will be a darkness
night slash moon god after all every
myth of a sun god is associated with a
night god as well so it really seems
more likely at this point to me that
blackbeard has such a mythical god power
rather than just a logia then there's
also the fact that the dark dark fruit
is called the yamiyami no me yes yami
can mean dark but yami also known as
yamuna is a goddess in vedic believes
she is the daughter of the sun god and
another name for her means night in
sanskrit she is often depicted in black
in tibetan beliefs she is a goddess of
death and rules the underworld if we
give oda some room for artistic license
as we always have to do it's easy to
imagine that he could make the yamayami
no me a god of the night fruit with
darkness powers that directly contrast
luffy's god of the sun fruit and he
could even keep yami in the name i do
also want to mention another specific
quote that comes again from ace and
blackbeard's confrontation blackbeard
mentions that this power referring to
the dark dark fruit chose him i don't
know about you but for me personifying a
fruit like this reminds me of the latest
chapter where the five elders did the
same thing with luffy's fruit they said
it's almost like the fruit was evading
them and then they said that's not
impossible since all zone fruits have a
will of their own so if we take these
two scenes together even though they are
separated by like 600 chapters it seems
to suggest that blackbeard's fruit has
to be a zone since it chose him just as
luffy's fruit has to be a zone if it
actually evaded the government and
honestly it probably chose luffy 2 in a
sense that day when luffy ate it in
front of shanks but let me know what you
think in the comments should we keep
trying to bend the rules of logia to
include blackbeard's dark dark fruit or
should we start questioning whether it
might be something else is there any
more clues that could support this god
of darkness theory that i overlooked let
me know i'd love to hear from you if you
did enjoy this video on one of the best
antagonists ever you know what to do
channel parking with it and smash that
like button with no mercy remember
smashing that like button is pyroking
energy and passing is scared orochi
energy so choose wisely if you haven't
make this the video subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece videos and updates and while
you wait for future videos to drop feel
free to check out my big and growing
one-piece playlist that includes videos
of all the yonko all fruits admirals
warlords and much more link to that is
in the description and i'll actually put
it on screen here too and until next
time see ya space cowboys